l'union européenne est elle trop
généreuse avec les vaccins qu'elle
produit c'est en tout cas ce que semble
penser bruxelles ce mercredi la
commission européenne a annoncé vouloir
durcir les exportations de vaccins hors
de l'union européenne
oui l'ipad et la police nous voulons des
livraisons fiables de vagues
nous voulons augmenter les contrats nous
voulons voir la réciprocité et la
sportivité dans les exportations et nous
sommes prêts à utiliser tous les outils
nécessaires pour y parvenir
il s'agit en sorte que l'europe a
reçoivent sa juste part we need to des
lèvres en date pour éviter les fuites
un premier système de contrôle avaient
été actionnés fin janvier depuis sa mise
en place ce mécanisme a approuvé plus de
300 demandes d'exportation pour un total
de 41 millions de doses seule une
livraison de 250 mille doses en
direction de l'australie a été bloqué
mais ce dispositif semble aboutir à des
résultats encore insuffisants selon
bruxelles oui si la situation ne change
pas nous devrons avoir une réflexion sur
les exportations vers les pays
producteurs de vaccins en fonction de
leur niveau d'ouverture en der nous
exportons beaucoup de vaccins vers des
pays qui ont produit ce même pour cette
une invitation à être ouvert pour que
les exportations soit dirigé vers
l'union européenne
cible principale de ces nouvelles
mesures le royaume uni qui possède
notamment deux sites de production du
vaccin astrazeneca bruxelles il y a
envoyé quelques 9 millions de doses
entre le 1er février le 9 mars soit
environ un tiers du total des doses
administrées sur place problème aucune
n'a fait le chemin inverse
malgré un contrat qui inclut les lots
produits sur le territoire britannique
visé par ces possible durcissement
londres s'étonne et demande des
explications
je pense que cela demande quelques
explications parce que le monde nous
regarde tout au long de la pandémie nous
avons tous
y compris avec nos amis européens que ce
serait une erreur de restreindre ou
d'interférer avec les approvisionnements
contracté d'également nous l'avons tous
dit l'année dernière à propos des
masques nous l'avons dit cette année à
propos des vaccins et d'autres choses et
cela va également à l'encontre des
assurances direct que nous avons reçu de
la commission et que j'ai d'ailleurs
suivi cette semaine et ces derniers
jours avec le vice-président borel et
nous avons été informés de manière
fiable qu'il n'était pas au courant de
plans visant à restreindre
l'approvisionnement légale du royaume
uni en bloquant l'exportation de vaccins
aux rues la commission européenne
souhaite renforcer une unité fragilisé
par les retards de livraison et le fait
que certains états membres envisagent de
traiter directement avec d'autres pays
tels que la russie israël ou encore la
chine un contexte qui pousse le
président macron à faire pression sur
les laboratoires qui produisent les
vaccins autorisés sur le continent je
soutiens les annonces faites par la
présidente de la commission européenne
en la matière et les décisions prises
par la présidente et le commissaire
breton visant à exiger de la part de
tous les laboratoires d'honorer les
commandes sur lesquels ils se sont
engagés avec les européens et en
particulier d'exiger aussi de la
réciprocité dans les mesures qui sont
prises dans l'ensemble justement du
monde
la présidente de la commission
européenne ursula von der leyen a
maintenu mercredi son objectif à savoir
vacciner 70 % des adultes de l'union
européenne avant la fin de l'été à ce
jour seuls 3,5 pour cent de la
population du continent a reçu les deux
doses nécessaires au premier trimestre
l'union européenne devrait avoir reçu
100 millions de doses dont 30 du groupe
pharmaceutique britannique astrazeneca